conspiracy theorist Alex Jones who  recently had about a billion and a half  dollars in uh Awards uh against him for  various defamation lawsuits has now  personally filed for bankruptcy now you  might say David I remember he already  filed for bankruptcy  Infowars filed for bankruptcy he is now  personally filing for bankruptcy  protection and things aren't going  particularly well for Alex Jones what we  all have to be careful of and when I  interviewed attorney Mark Bankston who's  the plaintiff's attorney who secured a  50 million dollar verdict against Alex  Jones in a defamation case in Texas is  will he or could he use these bankruptcy  declarations to actually avoid having to  pay out those settlements those Awards  and what Mark Bankston said is we have  ways of making sure that we get the  money that is actually available I  believe they will